all right thanks a lot for having me I'm
Patrick brown so I'm a postdoctoral
research scientist at the Carnegie
Institution for science right here on
campus and so in this talk it's gonna
probably be a little bit different than
a lot of the colloquiums you've had
because I am a climate scientist so I'm
not a computer scientist or electrical
engineer so you probably won't learn
much about computer science or
Electrical Engineering for me but you'll
at least hopefully see a pretty good
example of how other scientists and
other fields use the tools from computer
science and electrical engineering to
answer questions that they are
interested in so in particular in this
case I'm interested in how much gold
warming we're expecting to see over the
rest of the century so the title of my
talk is combining physical and
statistical models in order to narrow
uncertainty in projections of global
warming and as was mentioned this is
mostly a summary of results that we
recently published in nature and article
called greater future global warming
inferred from Earth's recent energy
budget so I'm just gonna kind of walk
through my title here as an outline so
what we're concerned here with our
projections of global warming and by
global warming here I mean the average
surface air temperature of the planet so
the surface air temperature is the
temperature of the air measured two
meters above the surface and then
averaged over the entire surface of the
planet and this is a plot that I'll come
back to a number of times but this is
observes temperature from the late 1800s
up to 2016 and the 2017 number will come
out tomorrow from NASA know and it'll be
right basically right on that model mean
that you're seeing there and what we're
seeing here is that we had this large
fanning or this spread of uncertainty in
terms of how much global warming we're
expecting through the remainder of the
century and so that'll be the main topic
that I'm focused on so before I get to
that I'm gonna
do a little background on the basic kind
of physics of global warming and climate
change science so we can understand
where this uncertainty comes from and
I'll talk about the physical models that
are used to project global warming into
the future
when I say physical I don't mean like a
toy car that you hold in your hand or
something I just mean physical to
distinguish it from statistical so
they're mostly based on physics rather
than just being empirical statistical
type relationships but then I'll talk
about our work in particular where we
combine information from these physical
climate models with observations and
with a statistical model to potentially
narrow uncertainty in the projections of
global warming
so first getting back to this
uncertainty in the projection of global
warming I just want to make the point
that this is pretty politically relevant
because you have things like the Paris
agreement and you'll notice the language
in the Paris agreement which essentially
all the countries of the world signed
and then we in a high profile move
dropped out of the Paris Accord but the
language in the Paris Accord talks about
global warming in terms of global
average surface air temperature so
exactly the variable that we're talking
about here so in particular they say the
agreement aims to respond to global
climate to the global climate change
threat by keeping global temperature
rise this century well below two degrees
Celsius above pre-industrial levels and
also they want to pursue efforts to
limit temperature increases to below 1.5
degrees Celsius so on this graph I've
put in the 2 degree Celsius limit so
basically what that means is that yeah
you just say a word about anomalies
versus average temperature yes sure so I
wrote all of these to a baseline earlier
in the century so it's taking all the
models and subtracting out the global
average temperature from that model so
that it essentially starts at zero
but the models do actually simulate a
real temper because their physical
models so they say the surface
temperature is about 288 Kelvin but
that's just getting subtracted out so
that you're seeing everything relative
to some 0 baseline and you can put that
baseline anywhere I just happen to have
put it so that they essentially start at
zero back here so any any uncertainty in
the future projections of global warming
will have political consequences in
terms of you know how much we would have
to reduce greenhouse gases in order to
stay below any given temperature
threshold so okay so getting back to
this Fanning uncertainty the first point
I want to make is that most of this
uncertainty doesn't actually have to do
with the physical climate system so most
of the uncertainty has to do with what
we call scenario uncertainty and that
has to do with these different colors so
these different colors are essentially
scenarios of the future where we're
imagining a given increase in greenhouse
gases and then the spread about any one
of those given things tells us about the
the physical uncertainty so the scenario
uncertainty is going to have to do with
technological changes and socio-economic
changes in population and various things
like that and so that is something that
you know geographers and demographers
look at trying to narrow and certainty
on but that's not what we're focused on
here what we're focused on here is
response uncertainty is what we call it
and what that is is it's basically
trying to answer the question how much
global warming should we expect for a
given increase in atmospheric
concentrations of greenhouse gases so
that's like if you zoom in on any one of
these scenarios each one of these
individual colors fixes the trajectory
of increase in greenhouse gas
concentrations and then the spread about
that it's showing you different model
calculations for how much warming we
should get when that trajectory of
increase in greenhouse gases is held
constant and so there's still a lot of
response uncertainty so the projections
differ by approximately a factor of two
the models that project the most global
warming for a given increase in
greenhouse gases protect about twice as
much global warming as the models that's
projects the least yeah so RC they're
just called represent representative
concentration pathways and all that
means is that greenhouse gas
concentrations are prescribed so just
defined ahead of time and then the
number next to that is the watts per
meter squared forcing on the system that
you get by the year 2100 so this our CP
8.5 means that we're defining ahead of
time that we were gonna have 8.5 watts
per meter squared forced onto the
climate system from an increase in
greenhouse gases okay so our basic
question how much global warming should
we expect for a given increase in
atmospheric concentrations of greenhouse
gases so I think it's helpful to think
about this question just in terms of
first principle physical equations first
principle thermodynamics so this is
essentially comes from the first law of
thermodynamics that we can think about
the change in temperature of the surface
of the planet and I'm gonna define it as
Delta T so a perturbation from the
equilibrium value is related to the heat
capacity of the system and then the net
energy flux imposed upon that system and
so if we think about the climate system
we can kind of think about this equation
in terms of just this one D you have the
ocean the atmosphere you have a land
surface you have space you think about
where would the net energy fluxes come
from in order to change the climate so
there's some you know geothermal energy
but very small there's some energy
coming from stars they're not the Sun
but for the most part it just has to do
with this energy exchange at the top of
the atmosphere that starts with the Sun
so coming in from the Sun we have 340
watts per meter squared some of that is
reflect
back to space by things like clouds and
then some of that is reflected back to
space by things like ice on the surface
right so I need or desert I need any
time you look at a picture of the Earth
from space and you see light surfaces
you're seeing short wavelength radiation
reflected back to space so about a
hundred watts per meter squared of the
energy that comes in from the Sun is
immediately reflected back to space both
from things in the atmosphere and from
the surface and then the rest of it is
absorbed by the surface and so we know
from plunks law that anything that has a
temperature is going to radiate and so
the earth is radiating but since it's
much colder than the Sun it's radiating
a much longer wavelength so we call this
infrared energy or call it a bunch of
things heat radiation and so that is
moving to space but of course that
interacts with things in the atmosphere
like water vapor and like clouds water
vapor and clouds actually make up 75% of
the current greenhouse effect of the
earth so they they absorb this radiation
and they remit it and they make it
harder for the earth to radiate this
energy to space but eventually it gets
out there and so what you have is a
situation in this case where you have
about 240 watts coming in because I'm
subtracting out the hundred that's being
reflected and 240 leaving so this would
be a net flux of zero right so this
would be no change in temperature with
time but you can think about then how
you would get a change in temperature
and so what's going on currently is that
humans are burning fossil fuels and so
they're adding carbon dioxide to the
atmosphere and carbon dioxide interacts
with this long wave radiation coming
from the surface of the planet much more
so that interacts with shortwave
radiation coming from the Sun and so it
introduces a perturbation where you're
initially as soon as you introduce
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
you're making the atmosphere optically
thicker in terms of the infrared and you
you are allowing less than
to escape to space and so you've created
a net energy flux then on the system and
so it's it's helpful to see where the
uncertainty and the warming comes from
if we break down this Q net flux term
into two different terms and so what
I've done here is I've broken it down
into what's called a forcing in climate
science and then a feedback term and so
the feedback term is generally described
by this lambda which is called the
climate feedback parameter and so the
uncertainty in the future projections of
warming doesn't really come from this
forcing so introducing co2 for example
into the atmosphere if you double co2
from 304 280 parts per million to 560
parts per million we know what forcing
that introduces on the system pretty
well that's within narrow bounds of
uncertainty so it's about 3.7 watts per
meter squared is what that does but
there's a lot more uncertainty when you
think about what happens to the net flux
and it has to do with what feedbacks do
so as soon as you start warming up the
planet you're gonna change a bunch of
other things so you can melt ice which
would change this flux you can change
clouds which would change this flux and
this flux you can increase you can
change water vapor which is going to
change this flux so all these other
changes come in and introduce
uncertainty in your warming rate because
of this feedback term so to get a better
idea of that we can imagine a situation
in equilibrium and then solve this for
the change in temperature and so
basically what this says is that okay
the change in temperature is related to
the forcing divided by this climate
feedback parameter and so there's a
smallest certainty in general for the
forcing at least going into the future
with co2 and there's a large uncertainty
in this feedback parameter which
represents what all these other fluxes
in the system do when you initially hit
it with forcing and so that then bleeds
into a large uncertainty in the
temperature
and so there are a number of ways the
climate scientists try to narrow
uncertainty in this climate feedback
parameter so I'll just kind of mention
one and put it off to the side because
it's not what our what our study looks
at but I think it's relevant to point
out that this is kind of a whole other
field of climate science is that you can
estimate the forcing and the change in
temperature over time periods in the
past and then try to get kind of an
empirical idea of what this lambda is so
we have all these estimates of how
temperature has changed in the past and
then we have estimates of how the
forcings
have changed in the past so this is
estimates of temperature change using
you know what are called proxies in the
in the G geologic record that that vary
with temperature and so you can try to
calculate temperature from variations
and say Delta o-18 in water in a water
column drill holes etc and so you have
you have these changes in temperature
this is over 65 million years over the
past five point three million years over
the past five hundred thousand years so
these are the so-called Milankovitch
cycles or ice age cycles and so what you
can do is you can say okay there's a
there's a change in temperature from the
last glacial maximum from the last ice
age to the present that we call the
Holocene so we can put that in there and
then we can estimate what the forcing
changes from from G geologic evidence
saying okay where the ice sheets were we
think they were like this and we can
measure from ice cores that greenhouse
gases were like this and we can measure
from other evidence you know what we
think the aerosols were looking like and
so then you can put that in there and
then get an estimate of climate
sensitivity that way so that's one way
of doing things but the other main way
that I will focus on for the rest of
this talk the strategy to is to increase
greenhouse gas concentrations in a
physical mathematical climate model and
have it calculate based on our best you
know physical understanding of the
climate system how much warming we
should get
so just some some background on these
physical global climate models so their
mathematical mechanistic for the most
part models of the entire Earth system
that in general need to be run on
supercomputers so this is the blue fire
supercomputer at NCAR the National
Center for Atmospheric Research in
Boulder and I think this is
seventy-seven teraflops and so I think
when it was installed in 2008 it was
like a top 25 fastest computer but of
course I think now it's orders of
magnitude behind the fastest computers
but these are the types of machines that
these climate models are run on and it's
not necessarily you know because the of
course because the code is long or
anything so they're typically about a
million lines of code which is less than
you know an operating system but they
are very computationally expensive they
require a lot of obviously a lot of
calculations and a lot of memory which
is why we need to use these and so these
cloud models are developed at centers
all around the world so this is just a
map of some of the most prominent
centers so this is the one I just
mentioned National Center for
Atmospheric Research in Boulder and you
have groups all around the world
developing models based on their own
best you know understanding of how to
move forward and they're kind of
competing everyone wants the best model
and so the way these models work is they
actually are modeling physically the
entire Earth's system so their system
gets discretized into horizontal and
vertical grids and basically just you
know the laws of physics are used to
calculate the state of the climate
system over time so just you know some
prominent examples you're gonna you're
going to be calculating the wind speed
at every grid point in three dimensions
based on conservation of momentum you're
going to be calculating temperature
based on conservation
of energy you're going to be calculating
mass based on conservation of mass so
density here you're gonna be calculating
water at any given location and you're
gonna conserve water with the flow so
all these things are just being
calculated at each time step and the
time steps are about 30 minutes so these
you know these equations get discretized
and then you just marched forward in
time and so you're simulating it's kind
of a misnomer to call them climate
models because they don't simulate
climate per se they're actually
simulating you know the weather because
they're simulating output at every 30
minutes and you can take that output an
average it together and get climate just
like you would in the real world if
you're taking observations every 30
minutes you average that together over
20 or 30 years and get some climate the
model is essentially doing the same
thing so these models have become more
sophisticated over time so the number of
processes that have been explicitly
simulated by the models has increased so
in the 70s people were interested in in
global climate change back then so
people were putting co2 into physical
models but back then there wasn't even
really there wasn't a land surface or an
ocean there wasn't clouds in the models
because they're just too hard to model
and so we've come a long way since then
so over time in the mid 1980s we start
putting in more you know the land
surfaces and everything and putting in
prescribed sea ice meaning that it's not
dynamic it just has to sit there and
eventually this these um acronyms here
correspond to Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change reports so this FA R
means first Assessment Report so that's
1990 and then SAR a second assessment
report third assessment report and then
a r4 is fourth assessment report because
F AR was already taken
so this is this is up to 2007 2001
nice 95 1990 but you can just see that
over time you know now we have
interactive vegetation we're adding more
and more things that may be important to
in terms of you know actually
calculating how much warming
or how much change you'd get in in
anything as you increase greenhouse
gases and then of course the spatial
resolution has increased as well as
computing power has increased so in 1990
this is what Europe looked like in a
typical climate model so only a couple
pixels over the entire continent and
then we're still for the most part
working with models that look more like
this so these global climate models
really should be taken with a grain of
salt when you're talking about any type
of local projection because the purpose
of them is really to project global
climate and there's various ways of
downscaling you can take output from a
global climate model and feed it into a
high resolution model over a given
location so that's called dynamical
downscaling or you can feed it into some
statistical model and that's called
statistical downscaling but for the most
part this is what global climate models
still look like a lot of them are
getting higher resolution and some are
run at very high resolution I'll just
show you an example of that right now
but for the most part over a short time
period so this is a video of a model out
model output from NASA and this is this
is that like five kilometers resolution
so this is getting to the point where
you're actually resolving the clouds and
in the model and I think this is useful
to look at just because it gives you a
sense of the type of emergent properties
that the model is simulating and it's
this kind of shows you exactly why
climate models are useful because you
have all these things in the system like
you have mid-latitude cyclones spinning
up you have hurricanes that spin up you
have so you can see the day moving
across the surface of the planet and
every time it's day you see you know
thunderstorms pop up in the in South
America you have all these things and
it's important to realize that these are
all just emergent properties of the you
know the model like there's no code that
says make hurricanes pop up and go over
here or there's no code that says make
the
circular twirl happen on this day that's
all just coming about from the basic
equations that are going into the model
and so that means that the model should
have predictive capacity right so if you
increase greenhouse gases in a cloud
model and it changes hurricanes that
wasn't begging the question necessarily
right that wasn't a situation where you
program the model to do something and
then it did what you programmed it to do
what it's doing is actually a prediction
it's a prediction based on physics for
the most part and so I think that's
that's one of the the key takeaways of
like why we would use these physical
climate models is for predictive
capacity totally off instead of initial
conditions predicted yeah actually so
that's another that's another important
point to bring up is that so in this
case this model this is only over three
months right and this is just an
atmospheric model so it's forced with
sea surface temperatures that were as
they were observed so it's not actually
in this case it's not simulating the
ocean it's that's like a boundary
condition on the model so what the
atmosphere does is not what we what
actually happens so these are real days
2005 this is so it's October 2005 and
it's forcing it every day with the sea
surface temperature that was observed
and the atmosphere does things similar
to what the real atmosphere did over
that time period but because of the
chaos in the system you can't take any
one of these you know situations too
seriously so like over the entire
timeframe you can say okay what was the
average precipitation over this
three-month period and compare that to
observations and you'll get like a
pretty close answer which is interesting
but the day-to-day weather variability
because that's part of the chaotic
nature of the system that's not
something that should line up that we
expect to line up perfectly with
observations and even if you take the
exact same model and you perturb
temperature in one grid point by 10 to
the negative 14 Thor something and
on that forward you get different
answers so that that chaos is in is in
the model as well and so if you can't
expect the model to reproduce
observations if it can't even reproduce
itself from such a tiny perturbation but
the longer time period that you average
over the more the more fair it is to
compare that to observations see
temperatures yeah a boundary boundary
better conditions but everything else
was you know initial conditions
predicted yeah
and that so most of the models I'm
talking about are not do not have a
boundary a sea surface temperature
boundary usually most of them have free
running oceans and so the only boundary
conditions that we're talking about in
these projections of global warming are
these increases in greenhouse gases
essentially and so then the atmosphere
is free running the sea ice is free
running the oceans free running because
obviously we can't prescribe for example
ocean temperatures into the future
because we don't know what the yeah
whether these extremes of weather but is
a similar weather pattern over the
period observed in terms of the extremes
in the model and in the real world so
I'm not explicitly involved in that
level of research or that particular
area research but my understanding is
that they are pretty confident that like
for example if you take hurricane
harvey's rainfall totals and you look at
a if you look at a model that was just
run perpetually in 1880 conditions and
you looked at like how often you get
precipitation values at given thresholds
and you compare that to a model run in
perpetual 2015 conditions you do see an
increase in these high-end precipitation
events and so that's that's partially
how they do that
tribution as they say they do like an
odds ratio they say like you know
precipitation event over 25 inches
occurs you know one out of however many
years in the in the previous climate
state and in the odds increased by a
given percentage in the new climate
state essentially just because you have
as the earth gets warmer and so we know
it's gotten warmer over that time period
you have a higher capacity of like
moisture in the atmosphere and so you
can have you can actually have nonlinear
responses where the you know the
temperature is only increased by less
than a percent if you think about
absolute temperature it's like 288
Kelvin has increased a 289 Kelvin but
you get these nonlinear responses in in
moisture converges because of non
nonlinear functions in the climate
system like closets clapper on which is
exponential the temperature measuring
didn't killed it really doesn't Bank
expands the range quite a bit because it
never gets down to 0 Kelvin right you
should look at it between maybe you know
minus 10 centigrade and 60 centigrade is
the entire range right but I'm saying
yeah when they did when they run the
models they're only looking at that
small range correct yeah yeah but wasn't
your question word aid stuff like the
ridiculously resilient Ridge and the
Jetstream funnies and that kind of stuff
right yeah so I think there's some
recent stuff on less sea ice and I think
know a different blog has some stuff
about that yeah it seems to be pretty
coherent with with those effects
jiggling and Jetstream worsened you know
giving us what we just have seen yeah so
the team at Stanford has have been kind
of pioneers in that their what their
research shows is that when you decrease
sea ice in the Arctic that lessens the
temperature gradient between the middle
attitudes and the Arctic
and that has an effect on the jet stream
where it essentially gets way here and
so you have more extreme events because
of a wavier jet stream I know that that
is disputed by other groups so that's
still active area of research that
people
are looking at which did you say or like
gave an example of a nonlinear thing but
are there several nonlinear effects sir
what are they yeah I mean a lot of the
so I mentioned clausius-clapeyron so as
you increase temperature you get an
exponential increase in the saturation
vapor pressure meaning that the
atmosphere meteorologists say holds more
moisture it's now atmosphere doesn't
hold moisture it's more just when the
temperatures is higher you can have more
moisture before it condenses and rains
out so that's probably the most
prominent one in terms of you know
importance to the to calculating future
warming because water vapor is a
greenhouse gas but you have you know you
have non-linear in the other direction
too so co2 for example saturates so
that's why we measure in terms of
doubling so each like doubling of co2 as
an equivalent forcing on the system
rather than it being like an exponential
so you look all over and you see you've
seen non-linearity all over the place
and some of its you know there's not it
not actually equations they're going
into the model it's like you could have
a non-linear collapse of the ice the
does arctic sea ice which we saw in 2007
and that would be some emergent thing
that happened because of all sorts of
processes working together and so that's
another reason why we want to run these
models is we want to see like you know
it's it's easy to say well co2 saturates
so won't get that warm and then someone
else says yeah but clausius-clapeyron is
in the other direction is so you
actually have to run the numbers right
you try to run the numbers and see what
what the results is yeah when I curved
it to the clausius clapeyron it ends up
at about seven percent increase in water
vapor content at equilibrium pretty
greasy mm-hmm it gets worse as it gets
warmer yeah that's my understanding to
seven percent so that to me was
mind-blowing yeah yeah and
what's interesting about that is that
the atmosphere holds some 7% more
moisture but the well I was gonna I was
gonna get into a thing about how about
why extremes increase but I think that's
too too far afield here but yeah that is
that is a that is a very it can be you
know mind-boggling thing in terms of how
much change you get for a small amount
of temperature increase okay so going
back to what the models in general look
like now if you want to run them for a
long period of time like hundreds of
years we have this type of resolution
and so what that means is that the
spatial resolution is not sufficient to
resolve many important processes in the
climate system and so those processes
then have to be parameterised in the
model we call it and what a
parameterization essentially is is that
you're calculating something based on
some algorithm or some formula that's
only really semi physical and is mostly
kind of empirical or statistical and it
has tunable parameters in it that are
pretty poorly constrained and so an
example of a parameterization like this
would be a cloud fraction so what the
model wants to do is it wants to
calculate say the cloud fraction over
this grid cell in Ireland and so what it
does in order to do that is it can't
just say oh when relative humidity is
100% there's a cloud because over that
that space is too big right so the
relative humidity isn't going to be a
hundred percent over that entire space
so it has to take in information about
relative humidity and a bunch of other
information from different other you
know physical variables and then
calculate what the what the fraction of
clouds should be over that grid box and
as you can imagine this is a relatively
difficult thing to do and there's a lot
of uncertainty and so I'll just show you
this is just some code for the cloud
fraction
sub subroutine in the community or
system model which is that model
developed at NCAR that i that i
mentioned you notice the code is in
fortran so most climate model most clam
elzar still run in Fortran I think just
for legacy purposes that they were
originally originally written in Fortran
and people share modules and things like
that all the time and so still written
in Fortran but you see it you know here
in some comments this calculates cloud
fraction using relative humidity
threshold pressure presence or absence
of convection is defined regionally a
large vertical mass flux etc you see
okay set weighing in SAS in parameters
so you have these ABC parameters here
set Schiller parameters so these are the
types of things that are important in
terms of what the actual module is going
to do for calculating cloud fraction but
they're not really physical you can't
really go out and measure them and so
they're very uncertain and so this is
where this uncertainty essentially comes
from as far as the models are concerned
is that different models make different
decisions on how to best parameterize
these sub-grid scale processes that then
have big effects on the radiation budget
and then how much warming you get in the
future so most of the uncertainty in
future warming from these different
models comes from uncertainty in the
feedbacks so how the other fluxes and
the energy budget change after you've
changed say co2 concentrations and that
uncertainty comes from these a lot of
these important processes being
parameterised in the model without like
a really good way of figuring out what
the best value is for those parameters
yeah are they all interrelated
so that when you alter one you know all
the knobs move in different direction
my understanding is for the most part
they are independent so you can you can
move them into
from each other and so you know some
projects do that is that they just take
one model and instead of running a bunch
of different experiments or whatever
their main goal is to just run one
experiment but to perturb all the
different parameters differently you
know at different times and see what
that does to the spread I think I would
say one man's constant is another
variable right okay so getting back to
then our study in particular is the
primary goal of our study is to narrow
this range of uncertainty and to assess
whether the upper or lower end of that
range is more likely and you can get an
idea of how we can do that based on this
discussion of where this uncertainty
comes from so the idea that we utilize
here is that the physical models that
are going to be the most skillful and
their projections of future warming and
thus have the most accurate
parameterizations right they should also
be the most skillful in other contexts
like simulating the recent past and so
you can says these models are kind of in
their own physical reality they're not
necessarily pinned to observations in
any meaningful way you can evaluate them
against observations of the recent past
to see how well they are doing and so
what we use is what gets called the
emergent constraints paradigm and what
that says is that if there's a
relationship between how physical models
simulate the recent past where you have
observations and how much warming they
simulate in the future that you should
be able to use this statistical
relationship along with observations of
the recent past to statistically
constrain or narrow that range of
uncertainty in a future warming so just
to kind of illustrate that the idea is
you have something that you could
serve currently which ends up being our
predictor variable and you have a bunch
of climate models that simulate that
variable differently so you have spread
in those cloud models and the the spread
actually is what is where the emergence
the word emergent comes from here is
that what they're saying is that because
different climate model modeling centers
make different choices and how to
parameterize different processes in the
model you just get this emergent spread
in how it will simulate various things
and then you want to relate that to
something that you want to know but you
can't observe so in our case it's how
much warming we're going to get in the
future so if the of all the models lined
up like this it would mean that ok the
models have different parameterization
choices etc and so that matters for this
predictor very rare but apparently it
doesn't matter at all for this predict
and so that would mean that our predict
and is is pretty well constrained and it
doesn't matter how these different
choices are army but for the most part
you'll see different relationships so
for example if you see a relationship
like this then you have spread in both
the predictor something you can
currently observe and then predict and
and so that's not very useful right
because then you then you can look at
let's say okay here's what our
observation of what this predictor is
but that doesn't help us constrain at
all the uncertainty in the predict and
so that's not what we're looking for
what we're looking for is something with
a essentially a strong statistical
relationship so you have something that
you can observe currently and that is
across models related to this thing that
you can't observe the predict and so
again in this case it's how much warming
we expect in the future and so if you
have something like this then you can
use this relationship and say okay
observations are here and so that means
that the models that are closest to
observations are telling us something in
terms of what our predicting
yes and it's the case or its hopefully
the case that then if we use this this
value this observation we informed
central estimate for our predict and
that will be better than just taking an
average of all of the models so it's the
idea of kind of ending model democracy
where instead of just throwing all the
models together and averaging them
together and saying the best estimate is
the average of all the models it's
saying no we can do better than that we
can we can use observations and this
relationship across models to try to get
a better estimate of what the prediction
the predict and actually is so in this
case the amount of future warming so so
we know what our predicting is that's
the amount of future warming and then
we're interested then in what should we
use as predictor variables so going back
to our energy budget diagram
remember there's large uncertainty in
temperature because there's a large
uncertainty in the feedback parameter
and the feedback parameter comes from
all of these different energy fluxes so
it makes us uses the predictor variable
especially if you're interested in
getting at how these parameterizations
might affect these feedbacks it makes
this uses your predictor variable these
actual fluxes so we use outgoing
shortwave radiation we use outgoing
long-wave radiation and we use the
difference between the two so the net
the net downward oriented energy flux
which is just the incoming shortwave
radiation minus these two so it's the
net down so we use these three variables
and then we look at them on different
time scales as well so we look at the
mean what's called climatology which is
just the average of those values over a
time frame I mean look at this at every
single location in space we look at the
magnitude of the seasonal cycle so the
standard deviation of the average
seasonal cycle in these variables and we
look at the magnitude of monthly
variabilities
if you take out the seasonal cycle and
you just do a temporal standard
deviation of those time series which are
monthly resolution what's the what's the
magnitude of that so with these three
variables and three attributes we have
nine predictor fields we call them and
so just to give you an idea of what
these look like these are model averages
for these nine predictor fields and so
we take these then and we use satellite
observations over this time period of
the recent past where we have good
observations so this is from the series
satellite record clouds and Earth's
radiant energy system satellite record
which is an instrument that flies on the
Terra and Aqua satellites run by NASA so
that's where our observations come from
and I'll just toggle here and show you
here's observations here's model mean
here's observations
here's model mean observations monoamine
and so you can see that the models do a
pretty good job of getting the
large-scale patterns right which is good
news and depending on your if you're a
optimist or a pessimist you might think
that that's pretty impressive or not so
I'm an optimist so I think that is
pretty impressive but these these
patterns that here's the models and
here's observations the fact that they
get these large-scale patterns correct
again is impressive because it's not
programmed into the model explicitly
it's just an emergent property of the
underlying physical equations but of
course some models do better than others
and that's what we're trying to exploit
here in the research and so we do have
kind of a statistical problem though so
we think about we have 9:9 predictor
fields well let's just focus for a
second on one and ask the question then
what method is appropriate to
statistically relate the predictor to
the predict and so we have this
situation like this where we have a
predictor variable which I'll call X
here and we have a number of models so
in this particular case we have
thirty-six models and so each one of
these I've by linearly interpolated them
to a very coarse grit compared to their
native grit but there's still a lot of
points so we have 72 longitudes and 737
latitudes and so we're trying to relate
all of these predictor variables to a
predict an which is just one value for
each model that's how much warming you
get in the future and so what we have
here is that there's way more predictors
than variables to actually predict and
the predictors themselves are gonna be
correlated with each other because in
you know geospatial fields you almost
always have a lot of autocorrelation
between grid boxes and so what we use is
essentially a method that's designed for
this situation where we relate the
predictors to the predict ants using
partial least squares regression which
was invented by Wald in 1966 and so to
give you an idea of how this works we
can think of this like it's a multiple
linear regression problem where the
predict and here is the Y value and the
the predict or matrix is X here and
you're trying to find B coefficients
such that they minimize this residual
right and so if you look at this this
matrix if we unwrap the predictor
variables in space and just put them in
one dimension so here 37 times 72
locations is 2600 64 locations and you
have 36 miles this way so the in this
this is an actual variable outgoing
shortwave radiation you have a situation
that's not appropriate for multiple
linear regression because the system is
way under determined right there's more
there's 2664 unknown coefficients and
only 36 equation and each column in this
matrix is highly correlated with other
in the matrix right just because of
their clothes in space this location 1
and location 2 are gonna be right next
to each other and if you regress them
against each other you get almost a
perfect correlation so that means the
matrix is well below full rank
so what partially squares regression
does is essentially solves this problem
by creating columns that are linear
combinations of the original column
which are orthogonal or uncorrelated to
each other but explain as much of the
variability in the predicted and as
possible so we essentially replace this
system with 2664 locations with a new
system where we have just a handful of
partial least squares components they're
called or latent variables so in this
case we tend to use 7 components but you
can use this as few as 3 and get a
similar results and so that that
essentially solves our problem of having
more way more predict doors than predict
and variables and then also having very
highly : your column so that original
matrix so however it is really important
to guard against overfitting in this
procedure
so the pls partially squares regression
procedure is more than capable of
overfitting predictors to predict and so
what we do to guard against that is
evaluate the skill and also the
constrained the narrow how much we're
narrowing the uncertainty and future
warming
using leave one out cross validation so
what that essentially is is we're taking
we're taking our linear combination of
pls components here so it would have to
be a linear combination to project this
into two dimensions but just bear with
me it wouldn't actually be into much
but you can just visualize it like this
here so that's our predictor variable
and then we have our predict and how
much warming we're expecting in the
future and so in this case this would be
like an observation and then our
observational informed prediction but
with leave one out cross validation what
we're doing is we're taking each model
and turn and we're saying okay this is
the test model we're gonna pull this out
of the procedure we're gonna do the pls
regression on the rest of the models so
that's gonna change this actual
statistical relationship and then we're
gonna pretend like this test model is
essentially observation so we're gonna
say okay let's say let's imagine that
this test model is what observations are
and then let's make a prediction of our
predict and based on what this test
model says for its predict or so that
gives us a prediction here and in if
this was real observations we'd just be
stuck at that we'd say okay that's our
prediction we don't know if it's gonna
come true but with a test model we
actually know what the value is right so
we have what the actual value is for
this model so then we can measure what
the error is between what the
statistical relationships said and what
the model actually predicted and again
of course the the statistical
relationship has to be blind to that
model has to be pulled out so that the
regression coefficients aren't using
that model so then we can do that with
every single model in the ensemble and
get a distribution of errors and that is
going to inform how well we think this
procedure narrows uncertainty in future
warming and so the way that we
summarized that is what we call a spread
ratio where the spread is just the
spread about the the predict and and so
what that is is just a root mean square
of all of these prediction errors for
each model divided by what the root mean
square error is if you just use the
model mean every single time
so if you just every single time you
guessed the model mean and you took that
as the error that's what we're comparing
it to and so if we get a spread ratio
below one that means that the partial
least squares regression procedure is
doing better than not using it doing
better than just using the model mean as
your best estimate and so that that's
how some of our results that I'm about
to show you are summarized with the
spread ratio below one means that it's
essentially working and then the other
part of the results are the prediction
ratio ratio which is just what the ratio
is between the observational informed
prediction of future warming and what
the model mean would tell you so if
that's above one that means that
observations along with the statistical
relationship together are giving you a
prediction of global warming that's
larger than what the what the multi
model mean would tell you it would be
okay so I'm gonna show you results
prediction ratio and spread ratio and
this is as a function of number of pls
components used and I'm showing here the
basically this is kind of a this is a
platform the figure that was supposed to
be you know like convincing to reviewers
because we're showing you all of the all
of the information but it's you know
it's not great for a presentation like
this but what what it's essentially
showing is that no matter which
predictor you use or we also vary the
predict Ann's difference for different
time periods in different scenarios no
matter how you switch that and no matter
how you decide how many pls components
to use you tend to get spread ratios
below one meaning that you are that you
are actually increasing the skill of
your prediction relative to just using
the model mean and you tend to get
prediction ratios above one meaning that
the observations are telling us in
conjunction with
statistical relationship that we should
expect more warming in the future than
we would otherwise if we were just
looking at the models by themselves and
ignoring observations and you see that
this saturates at about for the
prediction ratio this saturates at about
1.15 meaning that we're expecting about
15% more warming based on our results
than we would otherwise and so overall
what this plot is showing you is that
observations of several diverse
attributes of the Earth's energy budget
indicate both individually which is what
I'm showing over here and collectively
which that's basically taking all of the
predictors and using them simultaneously
in the pls regression procedure they're
both individually and collectively
global warming is likely to be greater
than that suggested by the unconstrained
model suite so to give you an idea of
what that looks like in terms of a
actual projection so here is the most
severe projection of global warming for
in terms of this is the largest imagined
increase in greenhouse gases of the
various scenarios so this is that our CP
8.5 scenario and this is what the raw
model spread is about that and so we
have observations of global temperature
here and then this is all smooth which
is why it comes to a point here that's
like the smoothing is the same time
scale as the time period that's used to
0-0 observations and models so we're
just looking at the spread into the
future this is what the raw cloud model
projections show and then this is what
our projections look like with
observational e informed information and
then that spread informed using the
cross-validation and so I think one
point that's worth bringing up here is
that it's sometimes argued you'll see
you know quite a bit on TV or even in
front of Congress
that projected global warming should
essentially be taken less seriously on
the grounds that cloud models don't
accurately simulate the current climate
system and what our work shows is that
there is a lot of room for climate model
improvement I mean we see a lot of quite
a bit of discrepancy between
observations and models but our results
suggest that models shortcomings really
can't be used to dismiss the most severe
projections of global warming because
we're showing that the models that do
the best in the current climate system
project more warming in the future than
the average model so if anything our
results suggest that that model
shortcomings can be used to dismiss
these least severe projections of global
warming so I'll just quickly show one
thing about physical mechanisms because
we want to understand you know what I've
shown so far is kind of a black box you
just take a predictor and you you
related to a predict and and it gives
you an answer but you don't know why but
something that's useful with the pls
procedures you can get an idea of the
physical mechanisms going on and so one
one way to do that is I'll just focus
here on this outgoing shortwave
radiation mean climatology predictor is
you can look at these what are called
pls loadings and I won't get into
exactly how these are calculated but
what this map means it positive values
are locations where models with more
outgoing shortwave radiation warm more
in the future and negative values are
mod mean that at these locations models
with more outgoing shortwave radiation
warm less in the future so you would get
a map very similar if you just went grid
box by grid box and calculated the local
correlation coefficient between outgoing
shortwave radiation across models and
the amount of warming that models
simulated in the future and so this this
tells us some information especially
when we add on observations so the
contours are the satellite observations
where
relative to the multimodal mean where
the pauses are the solid contours are
positive and the dotted contours are
negative and so you can see that the
observations it's definitely not perfect
but they they match essentially what the
pattern is they project positively on to
that pattern that you see from them from
the models and so just to give you an
idea of how we can use this to figure
out what's going on we see that for
example over the Southern Ocean models
that warm more tend to reflect more
sunlight back to space and so that would
mean that models that warm more in the
future have more clouds over the
Southern Ocean and or more sea ice and
so that makes sense physically why this
would matter for for warming in the
future just because of potentials so if
I think that it's easiest to think about
sea ice so if you have a model that in
the current climate state has a lot of
sea ice that means that as you increase
the temperature in the future there's a
lot of sea ice to melt and as you melt
more sea ice you're reflecting less
solar radiation back to space and you're
absorbing more and so it would make
sense that models with more sea ice to
begin with can melt more and then can
have a more positive feedback on warming
and we see that it also makes sense for
a short we have cloud feedbacks this
actually happens to be an area of
negative cloud feedback in the models
but what that means still is that if you
have more shortwave radiation reflected
back to space in your base state then
you have less potential for a negative
cloud feed back in the future and so
these both you know lend themselves to
physical explanations as to why these
predictors then actually work as as
being able to narrow the range of future
projected warming and so then
observations tell us since they protect
positively on to that tell us that
models with more outgoing shortwave
radiation over this southern hemisphere
region are correct and so then that
would
statistically then can be inferred that
the models that wore more are likely to
be correct okay so just to summarize all
that back to my title of combining
physical and statistical models in order
to narrow uncertainty and projections of
global warming we have all these
physical global climate models that are
you know calculating all these things
three dimensionally in space and
stepping forward in time and trying to
give us an understanding of the emergent
properties of the system and then we're
combining that that you know they have a
lot of uncertainty and how much warming
we're expecting in the future largely
because of uncertainty in these
parameterizations that affect how
feedbacks work in the system so we're
then going to use observations of the
Earth's energy budget which should be
related to how well models parameterised
various aspects of the climate system
we're gonna use that along with a
statistical relationship across models
to try to inform future projections of
global warming and so what we find is
that we can get a narrowing of the
spread so constrain that uncertainty and
that observations tell us that it's more
likely that the models that are
projecting more warming in the future
are likely to be correct so if anyone's
interested in reading more about that
this is the the name of the paper again
and I'd be happy to take any questions
yeah so about 20 years ago I was helping
sell supercomputers to the end car folks
neder and they characterized the
challenges to getting better models as a
mix of science basically being
parameterizations data availability and
then the third was compute power and I
said well I can help you with one of
those okay all right can you sort of
talk about the other two in terms
is there data more dating people wish
they had or their worries about getting
enough data and then how are the
parameter you know what you're going at
is which the parameterizations are
better or not mm-hmm so can you sort in
that framework yeah so I don't have a
lot of explicit knowledge of how the
parameterization schemes are developed
so you know we're kind of coming in at
the high level and saying okay
you know which one seem to be the best
but of course there's all these you know
different groups of scientists that
spend their entire careers just on one
on one thing so I guess I would I would
refer to talking to them about how
exactly they make those choices in terms
of data yeah we wish we had so much more
data wish you had they would help you do
this better well so longer records would
be a lot better so we're using this
satellite record from 2001 to 2015 and
there may be reasons why that could be
unrepresentative
of if you were gonna take statistics
over a longer timeframe so we have like
dictate oh there's decay de level chaos
in the system like internal modes of
variability like the Atlantic
multidecadal oscillation or the Pacific
decadal oscillation these things that
change over multiple decades in the
ocean and so if you just look over a
time period of 15 years you could easily
be catching in the system in a given
state that then the models don't
represent that not because there's
anything wrong with the models but
because they happen to not be in that
state at that time and so then in our
results that would feed into you know
the actual then projections of warming
is because you're you're downgrading a
model when it didn't deserve to be
downgraded essentially and so we'd love
to have more longer data sets which
means going into the future that we need
to continue to you know fund Earth
observing system things and especially
be like we don't know you know what the
forcings were going back in time
and so we have to you know infer that so
if you had satellite observations though
that would be helpful along that along
those lines well you know trying to
extrapolate things from ice cores and
tree rings I brought us in high scores
myself actually yeah
the offers other things which you
actually did very nicely touch about
early on about surrogates for
information about that yeah yeah - oh
there's similar kinds of things right
you mean awesome out here yeah you
scratch records
yeah it would be great to have you know
independent long-term records that like
because all these proxies are again
tuned to observations over the recent
past because you have to have some
statistical relationship here well it's
not just that - but also you know most
people would think about weather and
climate also have a big biased the land
right - yeah one of the oceanographers I
dealt with when I was in grad school
should be all the ship tracks and you
know very little ship traffic happens in
the sort hemisphere yeah and 9 States
Navy also takes a very different view of
satellites or flight or shots they
actively are against any sort of remote
sensing lotions that they don't control
okay
political thing to consider keep an eye
out Naomi Oreskes is doing it working on
a book sort of relates to that now I
talked to the people actually down at F
naught and internal West down in
Monterey like one of my old NASA buses
goes no supercomputers and Monterey Bay
go yeah that's two things I have a
friend who's a brilliant engineer I have
tremendous respect for him and he spent
the last 15 20 years
is wondering about an aspect of the
global warming crisis which is might
there be a space-based solution or
intercepting sun's rays there have been
things about war but in here he's
talking about finding solar sails and
the lagrangian point as a way of cutting
back a quarter percent and half percent
of one percent of the sun's radiation
before ever reaches mmm-hmm this may or
may not be practical I think he just
enjoys the idea things through but his
argument is that these models are so
complicated they could simplify things
to cut to the chase look for some
empirical evidence of what has happened
to global climate when there has been a
historic cutback and he's pointing to
something called a longer minimum yeah
that is there were a lot of sunspots it
was observed the time that would have
had the effect of cutting back the sun's
heat based on sunspot coefficients and
what happened to the Earth's climate
during that period how didn't capture
draw that seems like a very simple maybe
simplistic approach to not worry about
all these dozens of individual
coefficients but do you think there's
any grounds at all to trying to argue
from that vantage point well you can so
you know that one equation that I showed
that's just you know first off
thermodynamics like you can essentially
make a cloud model like that or the one
equation and so people people run the
gamut in terms of like cloud models that
are one equation up to these millions of
lines of code models so it's not
necessarily the case that these are the
only things that are studying the
climate system people definitely go with
much simpler models as well in terms of
the modern minimum which so that was
minimum in 1700 in the 1700s that we
think there was less solar output during
that time and temperature is also cooled
during that time quite dramatically that
actually if that is if temperatures
cooled as much as they did and it was
because of the Sun reduction that
actually has that's bad news for how
much warming we'd expect in a huge
because you can always convert you so
you can convert the change in solar
energy to a watch for meter squared
forcing just like you can look at the
change in co2 is a watts per meter
squared forcing and then look at that
temperature that was that resulted from
that and so if you have a small change
in solar activity and we don't think
that actual flux from the Sun varied
very much but you have a large change in
temperature that means the system is
very sensitive to changes in forcings
because you're gonna have positive
feedbacks amplifying that but of course
when you're looking over the 1700s the
data is not great you don't know what
the actual flux change was in the Sun
you're trying to approximate it from
sunspots and we only have so we have a
couple decades of sunspot records and we
can see the 11-year solar cycle but we
know we don't know if that you know
11-year solar cycle corresponds to
long-term changes in sunspots you don't
know what the forcing was and then you
don't know really what the temperature
change was within strong boundaries
because that you're using proxies from
tree rings and Carols and ice cores and
things like that so it's not as simple
as that in terms of geoengineering that
is a very relevant area of research that
my adviser is very much in Ken caldera
and so yeah there's a bunch of there's
many proposals as to how we could offset
the in heating influence from increasing
greenhouse gases and I have heard of
that other people suggest aerosols up in
the stratosphere to reflect solar
radiation cetera but yeah so that's
that'd be something one problem with
that is that you have to do that
continuously because co2 just
accumulates in the atmosphere so if you
do something like that like your spring
aerosol is up into the stratosphere that
has to be going on continuously and in
50 years down the road a hundred years
down the road we don't do it anymore
those things fall out in a matter of
years and then the temperature spikes up
to where it would be otherwise and so
that's what you're describing is several
different approaches that would be
basically earth based in Earth orbit or
the immediate vicinity of Earth and this
philosophy is if you could put something
at
Lagrange point oh I see and haven't
stayed there and have it be solar sails
that could maintain your position and
move as necessary that would be time
I'll open to hear any more problem is if
you look at the data at Grytviken most
recent ipcc stuff it's pretty strong
belief that a lot of the coolness of
that time was from heavy-duty volcanic
activity was also a approximately ten
parts per million drop of co2 going into
1600 that probably came from the 50
million person die off in the Americas
okay right there's a unique drop in co2
that happens 1525 to 1600 right but
volcanic stuff you know it's been better
calibrated now and looks like more of it
you know there's this claim by this lady
zhirkova that there's a big solar
minimum coming in 2030 or something but
every time people look at it just where
she doesn't make that much difference
we might might inhibit we might cancel
global warming for a decade or so
pretty nice look at the forcing diagrams
in the pcc ar5 could they go into that
wondering if any of those could be
teased out from Deek involving the
injection of sulfur dioxide choose the
Pinatubo other volcanic eruptions that
might be might be local before it's
totally distributed yeah um so that's
another that's another thing that people
do to try to get at this feedback
currently is that I mentioned the the
long-term changes
so I mentioned the Paleo climate changes
that you can look at some change in
temperature and some change in forcing
over these long timescales and try to
get at this feedback kraler
but then the Pinatubo thing is another
thing that people do exactly that is
that they estimate okay what was the
forcing from Mount Pinatubo in 1991 and
how much did it cool and so then we can
get the feedback from that so that is
another thing and people it's kind of
amazing that all these different ways
fine numbers are pretty similar to each
other but just not similar enough to be
able to narrow that initial uncertainty
that I was talking about but my Hanson's
models were actually pretty good on
Pinatubo is already called right because
they they ran the models they had at
that point in that did a fairly decent
job over the next couple years when they
yo stuff was up there yeah yes that's
always an it was sort of a classic first
hey we get these models actually okay
yeah especially when you can you know
predict an outcome without knowing the
answer first yeah in terms of building
models and having a forcing function
like Pinatubo or something or 911 was a
great one and I'll do the closest give
you some kind of data point servers or
any other thing besides that can give
you peace eclipses five enter short
events
things like that yeah so you're saying
basically something about the system
yeah I mean any any small perturbations
or an engineer loves to take a look at
how a system right right that's one tiny
policy response an impulse response yeah
but that's like 9/11 or all these even
if they're micro pulses that still give
you validation points yeah so something
else that's used is just the seasonal
cycle right you have this you have large
forcing over the seasonal cycle you know
temperature changes another one is just
using El Ninos and Lavinia's so
naturally when you have
you know the temperature of the earth
goes up by a couple tenths of a degree
and so then you can again you're trying
to figure out what this sensitivity is
based on okay when the temperature
increases naturally what does that do to
the flux at the top of the atmosphere
and so we can use satellites to try to
figure that or to measure that and then
get an idea of sensitivity that way so
you got a seasonal cycle kind of these
natural ups and downs in terms of your
year variability the Eclipse thing is
interesting I mean if you look at like
the path of totality of the solar
eclipse it's so small that like I don't
know how analogous that would be to to
the situation with global warming where
that's you know the co2 is such a well
mix greenhouse gas that's going around
the entire planet where in this case if
you're cooling locally and I'm not sure
how much it does cool locally but that's
cool just it was cool she was about a 10
degree drop okay yeah so you're gonna
change the circulation a lot but yeah
maybe maybe there is something there
with you know if you put an eclipse no
model and saw how it reacted versus well
do will example that I like is it
something like 1956 there are two crowns
of solid sunspots all the way around the
northern hemisphere ring all ring around
in the Sun there must have been much
more radiation than any of the other
typical averages average type models
okay so but could have looked at the
dynamic effects in 56 whatever yeah so
it just gets back so you know loving to
have more data yeah
or they focus on on rare events in some
sense and look how those can validate
your model right not just everything
right most compute things have faults I
mean you know you have CC distributions
so look for non Gaussian distributions I
can now help you validate even the gaps
in my comments yeah
what about the you know the massive
release of nothing from our early
consult for Nia Liz you know the
increase in methane concentration is
that how does that crack cannon terms up
here we had to to perfect yes
well so that's gonna be an interesting
question in terms of this model
development that he used to always be
that we would prescribe the greenhouse
gas concentrations in the atmosphere
because the carbon cycle or the methane
cycle or the nitrous oxide and cycle
which has to do with nitrous or nitrous
oxide like those are considered kind of
like too complex to even put in the
model so you would just prescribe you
just say here's what methane is gonna do
in the future and then if it does that
what would the rest of the system do
where now there's much more coming
online where the carbon cycle is
explicitly calculated in the methane
cycle it's explicitly calculated and so
then you prescribe emissions and then
you let the model calculate you know how
co2 in the atmosphere of a change or how
many an atmosphere has changed I'm not
sure what the state of the science is in
terms of method my understanding is that
like the Siberian methane bomb is not
something that we're worried about in
the near future in terms of you know it
didn't I guess it depends on your risk
threshold you know so if it's a one in a
thousand chance or something is that
something that you're willing to to
accept or not but I think it's a it's
numerically a small chance but then the
consequences would be bad what's what's
the susceptibility or the gain factor
purpura billion increase in monthly rate
so that thing is doubled at least double
minutes yeah so on a molecule per
molecule basis methane is much stronger
than right here - at its current
concentrations I mean part of that is
just because co2
there's so much more co2 here than there
is man you know so yeah I'm not sure
exactly what the reinforcing is for a
doubling of the methane from current
values there other than the other issue
is the time frame that you're looking at
so co2 isn't much longer life span in
the atmosphere and methane will decay
essentially into co2 so if you're just
looking over 10 years then the methane
you know spike would have a lot higher
amplification relative to co2 or then
over longer time periods it gets less
but does methane is it a straight
exponential decay in the model deserves
that no I don't think it is you're I
don't think it's assigned you know some
type of a half-life or something it's
actually calculate at least though that
there's a chemistry module that's gonna
be calculating how you know how much
methane there is based on a number of
factors but yeah I don't know the
details but yeah it's I think it you
used to be a case where it would just be
you know assign some decay function but
now they're more sophisticated than that
Fields biggest problem the lack of the
last half percent of procedure or is are
there bigger problems a little it's such
that we call this irrelevant in terms of
actually so do you mean I mean like I'm
mostly interested in these questions
just from a scientific perspective and I
think most climate scientists are you
know just the way that and you go to any
science department people are really
into their problem for no particular
reason other than just interest and so
that's how I feel about this I guess are
you saying that like that people in the
field are political and that that's a
problem where are you saying that oh I
don't know exactly what I'm thinking
in general engineering and science tries
to understand the real world so that you
can do something that might be yeah and
you know you you study computer
architectures so maybe you can come up
with faster computers right study global
warming maybe because you're hoping to
effective help us that may not be
possible to change that it may not be
lack of precision or detail that may not
be what's preventing people from yeah
you may already know enough so no that's
certainly true like changing these are
results relatives or the previous you
know results doesn't really change the
big picture and so I need any type of
political motivation to do something
about climate change shouldn't really
change all that much well a kid 1970
Keeling's last slide which I remember
was the amount the horizontal axis was
the amount of co2 in the atmosphere
might given steady the vertical axis was
the number of dollars so there's
practically a 90% correlation
and EP yeah this is again this is before
Al Gore by a decade right you put that
but we have to be mindful of the fact
when our results say when we publish a
quantitative figure like this with
respect to getting funding for what we
for what we want to study yeah the
analyze all this topic it's the same
problems we have now well yeah I would
just say that like alright so this is
what our results show right that we get
more we project more warming than than
the previous results in like it's clear
that that is a result that certain
groups like to hear right because it
advances an advocacy type stance but I
just want to say that like I would have
been just as happy if this was on the
lower end because it's either way it's
showing that we're gaining information
about the system that we didn't have
before so I think it's dangerous to kind
of if you're a climate scientist I think
it's dangerous to come at this problem
of like I only want to show results that
will motivate people to change their
actions or to do something politically
cuz that's gonna that's gonna bias the
results is gonna make it so that you're
not a good truth finder and so I I never
want to look at the problem that way
where where if I were to find that this
red line was below the dye line that I
would be somehow hesitant to publish
that or something because that would
mean that people would think that global
warming is less severe because my
motivation is just to get at the truth
and not to you know advance an agenda
and you know I think it's it's really
important that people say that because
the whole you know a large part of the
United States is very skeptical of
climate change science and they're
skeptical specifically because they
think climate scientists are just
activists pushing a political agenda
over science and so I'm you know
cognizant of that and very careful
you know investigating my own thoughts
on that and trying to make sure that I'm
not
doing that okay thank you
[Applause]
you